like you said it's not easy sort of  balancing your whole life trying to be  around your kids and spend time with  your partners and friends and time for  yourself and then also your career it's  so hard how do you do it I don't think  I've done it well necessarily yet I feel  like I'm constantly being pulled in a  million directions and I I know I think  I do that thing where I'm like it's all  great and inside is like a crazy turmoil  of ocean waves crashing and I'm freaking  out about trying to figure it all out so  the best advice one of the best pieces  of parenting advice is that was you  cannot do both at the same time when  you're wrestling on the floor you're  wrestling on the floor don't answer the  phone  don't look at a work thing don't text  somebody don't do any of it you are  wrestling on the floor that's what we do  in my household that's a lot of  wrestling  that track